للأحداث في الملعب على الجهة اليمنى
هجوم فريق ستافروبول يتطور
يثخن الضباب أكثر
أقل مما كانت عليه في بداية المباراة
أكثر والآن الهجوم قد لا يعرف
قم بتشغيل الضوء أو شيء من هذا القبيل لأنه ، حسنًا ، لا
لا يمكنك رؤية zgi كما يقولون ليس هناك ركن
لن يتم عرض طية صدر السترة
حارس مرمى Essentuki في هذه الحالة
تظهر على هجوم صريح الميدان
إيسينتوكوف
وبوابة منظمي المشاكل تستحوذ على
بهذا السيف نحن لسنا مستعدين للكرة هذه المرة
حصلت وخسر بسبب عادل
ركلة حرة إيغور Chernyshov وفي هذه المجموعة
ومن المدهش أن يقع Essentuki
في الجزء السفلي لتقديم عقوبة الكاميرا على الفور هنا
ولا ذروة ما هو دينامو بلدي
إيسينتوكوف
لذلك استأنفت النصف الثاني من الجمهور
بصراحة ، إنها أقل من
لأول مرة لا يمكن للجميع تحمله
استهزاء ببصر المرء
أشعر أننا لن نبقى طويلا ولكن في الوقت الحالي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مرة أخرى الكرة على الجهة اليمنى
تمرير sorokin عاطفي مع الكرة